[Musique]
on
mais
il regarde toujours vers demain n'est à
poissy il a déjà plusieurs vies des
études d'art dramatique pas de carrière
de comédien mais des études de
réflexologie plantaire où il masse des
salariés tendu de grands groupes
et c'est là qu'il découvre qu'il peut
aider les autres cyril dire bonjour
alors vous êtes révélé au grand public
le film documentaire demain vous écrivez
et co réalisé que mélanie laurent leur
succès en salles plus d'un million de
spectateurs plusieurs prix très trois
ans plus tard mon bilan peut-être un
bilan personnel c'est que ça
profondément changé ma vie ça m'a donné
la chance à ces extraordinaires une fois
dans ma vie d'avoir
produit quelque chose créer quelque
chose qui a pu rencontrer les autres a
priori être utile à un certain nombre de
gens et et apporter des résultats
tangibles et ça enfin je me dis si même
si ça m'est arrivé qu'une seule fois
dans ma vie c'est déjà une chance
incroyable
et puis bilan pour les autres mais le
film sorti dans une trentaine de pays
il a donné lieu à plein de projets
puisqu'on a on a recensé plus de 1000
projets sur le site internet du film est
là on a fait un documentaire avec une
journaliste qui s'appelle laure noualhat
qui est parti enquêter sur l'impact que
ça avait pu avoir et justement qu'il
allait rencontrer des gens qui avaient
monté des projets suite à demain pour
voir ce que c'était devenu pourquoi ça
avait marché parfois pour que ça n'ait
pas marché d'autrefois donc vous
attendiez à un tel impact
non non c'est que là la confiance
commence à être prise
oui bah de toute façon c'est sûr si le
film à marcher comme ça c'est parce que
c'était le moment parce que tout d'un
coup on a rencontré
une époque les interrogations que les
gens avaient
des angoisses peut-être une envie aussi
de s'y mettre
donc et montrer des choses positives ça
tout ça montre aussi qu'on peut faire
quelque chose
oui oui et puis on va aborder les choses
de façon un peu original par rapport à
ce qui se passe est d'habitude on a
montré qu' il y avait des gens qui se
bougent avec i qu'on pouvait aussi
changer un peu d' imaginaires par
rapport à cette question de la crise
écologique
alors on se rend compte ce soir à saint
quentin en yvelines ce que vous
présentez votre dernier ouvrage le petit
manuel de résistance contemporaine il
est publié chez actes sud une réflexion
pour transformer le monde
on continue avec demain oui mais c'est
une sorte de suite logique
entre temps j'ai publié un roman qui
s'appelle imago chèque de sud à la
rentrée littéraire dernière ce qui m'a
permis de penser un peu à autre chose et
de parler un peu d'autres choses aussi
c'était bien c'est une attente très bien
et là bas le livre était supposé sortir
en même temps que qu'après demain et
puis ça a été repoussée par france
domaine
j'ai essayé de théoriser un peu sur ce
qui s'est passé de comprendre pourquoi
demain avait fonctionné comme ça ce qui
ne continuer à ne pas marcher dans le
mouvement écolo et puis essayer de faire
des propositions complémentaires et
notamment des propositions de stratégie
donc moi ce qui m'intéressait beaucoup
c'est de voir que le succès de demain et
est entre guillemets la preuve que quand
on produit un récit quand on raconte une
histoire qui est suffisamment bien foutu
désirable touchante même par rapport à
ces questions ça donne de l'énergie
ça suscite de l' enthousiasme ça
entraîne des gens dans une volonté de
faire des choses c'est ici aussi pour
l'écrire vous êtes allée auprès des gens
trois ans après demain comment vous avez
fait ou c'est vos réflexions avoue
personnel bien en fait
pendant de plus de deux ans j'ai
rencontré les gens ce que j'ai été dans
19 pays je crois plus de 200 villes donc
j'ai pas arrêté de faire des débats je
sépare et et aide d'avoir des
conversations j'ai pas arrêté d'avoir
des projets qu'on présentait en me
disant voilà on a fait ça suite à demain
donc c'est effectivement toutes ces
réflexions tout c'est tous les
questionnements que j'ai pu entendre
tout ce que ça m'a obligé à élaborer
dans mon petit cerveau fatigué que j'ai
essayé de 2 retransmettra en disant
finalement toutes les questions qu'on
m'a posée pendant deux ans je vais
essayer de répondre une bonne fois pour
toutes son nom dans le bouquin et puis
tout ce que j'ai l'impression d'avoir
compris depuis que demain est sorti et
qui peut-être voir un peu plus loin je
vais essayer de mettre aussi alors vous
êtes auteur avec toujours un réalisateur
on l'a bien compris tout est militant
écologique ça fait de nombreuses
casquettes au service de la planète et
aussi au service des autres oui
après je je
j'essaie de faire des choses qui me
passionnent aussi j'essaie de le faire
pour moi j'ai justement arrêté un peu de
faire du militantisme sacrificielle
après avoir fait un bon gros grain
autant 2012 où ce truc de je vais sauver
la planète
enfin ça y est un endroit où ça marche
pas on est on essaie de réparer
finalement des problématiques
personnelles à l'extérieur dans le monde
et c'est pas forcément très sain c'est
important de savoir pourquoi on fait les
choses
donc maintenant j'essaie d'articuler les
deux c'est à dire de de faire des choses
qui m'épanouit ce dans lesquels je pense
avoir un peu de un peu d'aptitude un peu
de talent et en même temps de faire en
sorte qu'elle soit utile aux autres
comme maximum alors on va remonter un
peu en arrière pour comprendre un peu
tout ça vous naissez à possibles grandit
service mais le lien yvelinoise qu'il
est toujours là déjà
bah oui c'est ma maison est ce que ça
vous a permis notamment de développer
ses passions ses envies de décrire de
filmer je peux si ça m'a permis mais en
tout cas ce que j'ai gardé des yvelines
puisque l'effectif ans j'ai grandi du
côté de chatou vésinet où j'ai été à
l'école et puis après j'étais au lycée à
saint germain en laye c'est la forêt en
fait les yvelines c'est un département
il ya énormément de foire et donc moi
j'ai j'ai besoin de la forêt c'est là où
je vais me ressourcer c'est là où je
vais marcher pour avoir des idées
maintenant j'habite à dreux il ya une
fois réussi à côté donc c'est chouette
pour vivre près de ces espaces verts
avec nos soins intensifs
les forêts à côté c'est sûr et puis au
vésinet sa boîte un ghetto de riches
c'est aussi une sorte de ville parc qui
a été construite comme ça donc c'est
vrai que c'est hyper grave mais on est
tout le temps dehors
pour moi quand j'étais gamin on était
pas et il n'y avait pas de smartphone à
l'époque donc on était plutôt sur les
pelouses avec des guitares et sous les
grands arbres et c'est vrai que j'en ai
gardé une espèce d'attachement à ça j'ai
bougé besoin de ça là vous confier à des
confrères que vos lors de votre
adolescence de fait une promesse n'est
jamais faire quelque chose qui ne vous
passionne pas est-ce que c'est toujours
le cas bah oui j'en parle avec mon fils
encore un tout à l'heure parce que je
sais plus pourquoi on parlait de oui il
m'a raconté qu'un de ses copains
voulaient devenir agent immobilier à
rigoler il veut que je lui demandais
pourquoi qu'est ce qui l'intéressait là
dedans et ça pue on parlait de ce métier
là et qu'ils aimaient ça gagne bien je
sais pas quoi enfin bon et donc on est
on est rentré sur ce terrain et je
disais mais tu sais le truc c'est pas
forcément que ça gagne c'est que moi si
je si j'avais pas besoin de gagner
d'argent si j'avais aucun problème
matériel je pense que je ferais la même
chose et il me dit qu'ils n'ont même
disséquons si tu avais pas besoin
d'argent
tu pourrais rien faire je dis mais rien
faire ça n'intéresse pas de rien faire
je préfère faire des choses que
justement qui le matin même à qui il
donne envie de me lever et je crois que
je ferais pas autre chose cerqueux
force est aussi liée à la crise
écologique celle ci avait pas la crise
écologique je pense que je passerais
plus de temps à écrire des poèmes et des
romans ou à faire des films sur la
nature humaine que à faire des choses
sur la crise écologique mais je ferai
quand même des films et j'écris des
livres ça c'est sûr mais justement
qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé dans cette
fibre écologique à vouloir défendre la
planète et informer les gens quel a été
le déclic
un mouvement dans votre vie non enfin je
moi je croi pas tros déclic fin si
parfois il ya des déclics mais moi je
crois que ça a plutôt été une espèce de
processus d'implémentation
à force je pense que j'ai commencé à
être sensibles un peu à la question
quand j'étais gamin parce que non moment
était très magasins diététiques
l'ancêtre des magasins bio donc on sait
déjà les courses là-bas donc ça passait
plutôt par la santé
après j'ai fait de la médecine naturelle
parce que ma chère était malade à ce
moment là et qu'on trouvait pas de
solution dans la médecine allopathique
donc je me suis intéressé la médecine
naturelle et là aussi ça m'a sensibilisé
aux questions de d'écosystèmes de
comment fonctionne le corps de pollution
chimique
bon et puis après à partir de 2004 2005
on a commencé à parler d'écologie
beaucoup mais le défi pour la terre cpt
avait été lancée par la fondation
nicolas hulot
je me souviens
un bouquin de tirer tout venant un
ancien du wwf sur les premiers gestes
pour la planète et et je pense que c'est
un truc générationnel serre que ça m'a
tout de suite parlé je me suis dis bah
oui oui mais c'est important
et puis je trouve que avant d'être
de diriger colibri de diriger une ong
j'organisais des congrès israélo
palestinien il congrès d'imams et drama
pour la paix et quand j'ai arrêté ça en
fait une de mes anciennes collègues m'a
proposé de rencontrer pierre rabhi pour
créer un mouvement autour de ces idées
que vous créé en 2007 d'ailleurs voilà
enfin fin 2006 en décembre 2006 et est
en fait je là j'ai fait une espèce
d'éducation à l'écologie un peu accéléré
vous attendrez qui marche aussi bien que
onze ans plus tard on est quand même à
300 mille sympathisants 100 groupes
locaux
ouais bah non g20 je me souviens quand
on a commencé très marginale c'était
hyper marginal avant on faisait une
réunion je me souviens le double double
vous avez prêté un bureau il faisait une
petite réunion
avec les quelques personnes qui a eu
l'idée de monter ce mouvement et on se
disait on à un des premiers objectifs
une sorte d'indicateur qu'on pourrait se
donner pour qui nous permettrait de nous
dire que nos idées commencent à être
entendues dans la société ce serait que
pierre rabhi passe un journal télévisé
et à ce moment là ça nous faisait
rigoler ns et pierre rabhi journal
télévisé très drôle on n'y arrivera
jamais et maintenant ça paraît normal
parce qu'il est très connu voire même il
est attaqué par des écologistes plus
radicaux qui disent ses invendus du
système parce que il
il s'inscrit dans des médias qui est
très connu qui vont beaucoup dire mais
en fait il fait enfin voilà il faut se
rendre compte qu'en quand on a créé
colibri on était de toutes petites
associations de personnes connaissaient
dans tout dans ce fichier est en jeu
cyril dion de demain quels sont ses
projets ses inspirations et crée encore
à la rencontre des genres j'imagine well
as j'aspire en fait allé un peu moins la
rencontre des gens là parce que ça fait
trois ans que je tourne tout envoyer ges
que j'ai tourné avec demain j'ai tourné
avec le roman et là je parle de la
lâcher encore en promotion pour un livre
est à la fois c'est formidable mais à la
fois j'ai besoin d'avoir du temps pour
écrire la et de retourner un peu dans ma
vie dans ma caverne
donc là je suis en train de parler
j'ai terminé un documentaire avec laure
noualhat donc qu'il va passer au mois de
décembre sur france 2 je suis en train
d'écrire un film de fiction là j'essaie
de parvenir au bout du scénario et je
suis pas loin
il était chargé voilà et puis je démarre
deux autres projets super un
documentaire pour le cinéma là sur le
pourquoi est ce que les animaux
disparaissent de la surface de la
planète et comment on pourrait enrayer
cette disparition est une série pour
arte sur la régénération
on va aller sur les cinq continents voir
des initiatives qui participent à
régénérer les écosystèmes pas simplement
des choses qui polluent moins qu'ils
détruisent - mais carrément qui régénère
merci beaucoup c'est avant tout avoir un
côté de votre temps avec plusieurs
[Musique]